all right welcome to a very special
edition of beginner breakdown I'm your
host Mike color we are live at the Swiss
Miss Swiss tournament today we got some
great players in the field today
20100 Jim McLaughlin in the open section
expert extraordinaire Alex Marlar
assistant manager of the Chess Club
beginner breakdown a hero Jonathan
Krantz is also in the field and then we
have some other players namely Harper
Evan Smith I have one prediction today
that a Harper will not be red in 1900
after this event so here's Harper in
this first round game against Manny he
is the winner of October nights he
defeated Adam Eubanks in the last round
here is Harper's game he has the white
pieces and he was 40 minutes late for
the affair okay so he starts out d4
black counters d5 white plays c4 and
black plays good c6 the Slav defense
here right brings out his Knight to c3
black counters Knight f6 right brings
out Knight f3 so let me ask somebody
from the audience here Derek how would
you go about getting this Bishop into
play
excellent
so Derek wisely says before he gets
seasick sin maybe get this Bishop out of
the pawn chain first unfortunately right
away it wouldn't work because white has
the splendid move Queen to b3 or we
could just play a g6 here okay and then
then you know then Bishop to g7 and now
our white Bishop you know it's still
free to go however black plays the move
ecigs here and now his bishop is stuck
behind the pawn shame so Harper C's sees
what uh what black just did how he
trapped his uh Bishop so he says let me
beat you to the punch let me let me do
that - it looks so good so now his
bishop is stuck behind the pawn chain
remember the more mobile or pieces are
the better they are hello welcome to the
welcome to the lecture all right so now
he really doesn't want this bishop to
move so he plays the move Knight to d7
not recommended all right so now he gets
his a fish about so now we had a Boy
Scout event last week here and there was
a question on the test and let's see if
you guys can get the question what is
the most important part of the board
all right the center okay
this Center that is the correct answer
but the answer the Boy Scout wrote down
the number one answer was B 4 ok the
square e 4 so right now which side
really doesn't want to
a piece on e4 white are black like would
it be safe for the white knight to go to
e4 in this position no because he could
capture it so so the black side has
complete control over efore right now so
the last thing he wants to do is give it
up so a very non positional move for
black in this position would be to take
this pawn and that's what he did so he
thinks he's just trading pawn for pawn
but he's actually giving up control of
e4 now okay so not recommended okay so
he attacks the bishop bishop goes back
to d3 I in that efore Square so now he
plays Bishop b7 and now Harper can just
play E for or castle and and now he can
get in e4 and he's he's well on his way
see how now White has I turned the
tables and now it's controlling the
center so you don't want to give that
Center up okay so he's trying to
undermine the center here so Harper
advances the pawn attacks the bishop
bishop goes back queen up rook protects
the pawn alright because al Queen Bishop
when they're in the same diagonal that's
called a battery they're aiming at this
h2 square but luckily the knight has it
defended so everything's okay so he
attacks the bishop here okay our Bishop
attacks the night okay so what are some
ideas for for black here does anybody
have any ideas so what when when he
played Bishop attacks the night do you
see a deeper threat that White has so
let's say black besides the
hasil in this situation okay if Bishop
takes Knight
how does uh how does black have to take
back in this position how would Manny
have to take back yes okay so so that's
how Harper is hoping that he takes
because ideally you really wouldn't want
to break up you know your your Castle
here with you have double pawns so so
you're like I'm taking back with a
knight but unfortunately White has a
good move here taking advantage that
your Bishop and night or on the same
rank the sixth rank here and they're
just one file apart he can implement
this pawn fork okay
pawn attacks the bishop and the knight
so if Bishop takes the pawn Knight takes
and he can't capture back everybody see
that that's up called a pawn fork okay
so so he really doesn't want to fall for
the pawn fork so knowing that when
Bishop takes Knight he'll have to take
back with the Jeep on he decides not the
Castle kingside but Castle queenside
here and putting his rook in a pin here
alright but Harper doesn't lets do much
about that he plays a three rook to e8
Queen up captures Knight captures so now
captures and capture so now White has
it's called
a passed pawn okay but there's a lot of
things in the way but there's no pawn in
the way it's still considered a passed
pawn but it's going to be really tough
for him to promote the
considering there's a bishop and knight
in the way here all right so black plays
the move f6 does everybody know about
this move f6 it's not very good okay it
it weakens your position mightily all
right so if you think you really want to
play f6 look harder and find another
move okay so f6 is not the answer even
though it attacks the bishop
all right so Bishop back Knight to b6
attacking this pawn bishop checks the
King King moves out of the way and now
the bishop comes in and can protect the
pawn if your poem was still on f7 that
wouldn't be possible all right so g5
attacks the bishop bishop moves back all
right you might as well take it and you
give your opponent doubled pawns double
pawns or when there's pawns on the same
file okay
Queen attacks the pawn the bishop so
rook protects the Queen here okay so so
we might have an idea here how many
players of black or attacking d5
one two three one two three okay so we
got three attackers however how many
defenders does white have so we and then
we can count the rook as well because
he's defending it through an x-ray okay
so we got three defenders normally the
math doesn't add up
you need more attackers than he has
defenders however we have a little trick
here so if we take with the bishop here
and then Bishop takes back okay so now
notice our rooks can capture so we come
down and capture so now if he takes with
his queen or rook
we're in business right cuz then he's
he's taken away a defender from the
bishop and we'll be great so he decided
to take with the night here okay so it
looks like Wow
we're down apiece all right however we
can get this piece back if we just
attack it one more time so so who else
that's not currently attacking this
bishop can come in and join the attack
the rock yeah and now this Bishop he's
got no place to go cuz if he moves he
can't legally move but then we'll just
go Queen takes rook takes rook well we
don't wanna go there when we'll have to
take it all the way and then we'll be in
business
okay unfortunately Manny doesn't see
this tactic and he falls apart pretty
soon because you see how he's just
obsessed with this pawn right now
everybody's attacking it but he never
finds the way to actually take it oh hey
he's got a lot of threats but it never
goes anywhere
so rook up rook attacks now Harper's got
so many defenders on it and it's it's
gonna be really a really good for him
so now Harper's uh attacking the knight
some more so he moves the knight Harper
just takes off six then three four
protects it
Bishop attacks and so now you can just
take they know if there's pawns hanging
just take them and and now after Bishop
takes Bishop pawn takes and manny has
had enough his a queen is now under
attack he can't take this pawn back or
else he'll get checked so he's pretty
much had enough so hard were after round
1 advances to one and oh okay
so now we're gonna check out some games
from the under 1700 section here we have
a a kid here he's playing the white
pieces and he's taken Grandmaster
lessons and he's playing a guy from
Belgium that's playing his first
tournament game so let's see how fast
things can go from good
too bad to worse okay so white starts
out the Queen pawn opening this is
called the English opening here okay so
black comes with this net out to f6
Knight to c3 c5 you know in openings
like these pretty much both both players
aren't really like attacking each other
they're just developing getting their
minor pieces off the back row castling
but none of their moves are really
corresponding to each other's very well
here 90 to b6 castles okay so now White
has fianchettoed that's putting the
bishop on this long diagonal and black
has as well okay so white plays a3 here
black gets castled and rook to be one
all right black plays Queen DUP so now
after d4 captures and captures so that
lets his bishop free here and black
plays a6 so now if you had if you were
playing white here what are some ideas
here because unfortunately this is where
white White's has an advantage here but
but he doesn't get the right idea and
quickly loses so so look your rooks on
b1 right so what is he attending to do
maybe you just played b4 get some Queen
side space your bishop has not been
developed where's a good spot for this
bishop to go you want to attack
something
you simply play a Bishop f4 but
attacking the Queen okay so those are
some just just basic ideas you could do
you know unfortunately like most
beginners they're like let's trade let's
trade pieces it's going to be great
let's trade pieces so by playing is
Knight to e4 if you put place if you put
your pieces where they can get captured
expect them to get captured you know you
should be looking at that so after a
knight takes the bishop takes and now
this bishop for white is very good I
mean it's holding everything together
down here okay so now when he plays
Knight to a5 it's a discovered attack
queen is now threatening the pawn so was
the knight and the bishops are under
attack here okay so white should just
take here and then after black captures
back defend the pawn here okay you don't
want to be losing pawns okay but instead
he decides to play Bishop back to g2
this is not recommended because now
black can swoop down and take and King
takes and now look at how this King can
now get checked
we got check here we got checked there
obviously we won't play these checks
because they don't help blacks position
in this in this certain position it
would just get his King back to safety
but in the future we can use this to our
advantage okay so now as Kings is on g2
and now we can take the pawn we can take
the pawn with the knight or we can take
it with the Queen any ideas well in this
position he just takes with the knight
the Knights not really doing much on
this back row here so he takes okay and
now white plays a substantial blunder in
this
position he's like wow this Knight and
queen are lined up on the same line I'm
going to pin it with my queen hoping
that he'll he'll black won't play
anything and he'll play b3 and he'll be
in business however little does white
know it's a catastrophe so if we can
look so it's true the the the knight is
in a pin but it's not an absolute pin
meaning the knight can move but there
could be repercussions as as the Queen's
or will be under attack so whenever this
Knight moves the Queen is under attack
right all right so see if we can fight a
really cool move with that night because
remember if this Knight moves the
Queen's under attack and notice that
while both Queens are unprotected yes
Knight - III check and you're like wow
you just gave me a free night thanks a
lot but it was a discovered attack on
the under Queen here right and we won a
queen so whenever you're playing in the
game always try to look for your
captures and your checks and if people
if you got a pin going here and they're
really excited look at ways you can get
out of a pin utilizing a check and then
the joke is on them
okay very good all right mister Millie
is playing a Elliot now our hero has the
black pieces so we'll flip the board
here all right so white starts out very
common efore black plays d5 white plays
Knight to f3 attacking the
on so black defends it alright Bishop to
b5 so by now we shall know that this is
called the Rory Lopez alright so we'll
see if if they can play it correctly so
so negative six perfectly acceptable
move you don't need to play a six
negative six is fine
alright so nine if six attacked the pawn
so he protects it Bishop c5 I mean this
f2 Square and now Elliott plays b3 this
is not conducive with the wari Lopez
opening right you want to play maybe d3
or get castled
b3 is not advisable alright
so black gets Castle white fianchetto is
the UH the bishop here and so now black
plays d6 he just activated one of his
pieces which piece that d6 just activate
the light square bishop Thank You Derek
alright where do you think this this guy
really wants to go like if he could go
anywhere in this position well as you'll
see white gets castled so where did we
want to put this Bishop g4 excellent
putting that night in a pin okay because
if the knight moves the queen is dead
alright so so now we just put the knight
in a pin okay so Elliot playing white
decides to do nothing about it and plays
d3 okay even though it all it does is
extra protect of d4 okay so now this
Knight is in a pin it's very important
we know what to do when pieces are in
pins I'll give you three options we can
do nothing we capture them or we can
attack them what do you think is the
best option so if we do nothing like
just move our rook somewhere Oh
that really doesn't help anything right
if we capture the pin piece then you
know white doesn't have to worry that
his pieces in a pin anymore and he just
activated his his other piece in the
Queen right so that really didn't help
us but if we attack the knight will be
piling on attackers until white will
eventually crumble okay
so who can attack this knight on f3
so the bishops doing a good job who can
join in the fun
just if you have to just look at every
single piece a rook can you jump in the
in the fire you're like no the night no
Queen no you can just keep going one by
one by one until you find that somebody
that can help out yes yes this the
knight on c6 yep he can jump in and
attack okay so now we have two attackers
on this pawn going this Knight here all
right so he really doesn't have a
response here so he plays Bishop to c4
now there's nobody else there there's no
other attackers we can get on to this
Knight
I mean we could try like night here and
then queen up maybe but we're gonna have
adequate compensation for capturing this
Knight now because we're going to be
able to destroy white's castle and
that's great so how would we take the
knight here with the bishop or the night
the night one it's checked so that's
pretty cool and two we'll get our Bishop
right here all right
right in this castle okay we're like
knocking right on the door okay so now
the rook moves so now we're close to
checkmate
we should be envisioning the checkmate
right now where do you think the
checkmate is going to a
I give you a hit it's probably right
there on g2 so who would have to deliver
the checkmate on g2 now Queen yes see if
we get our queen of g2 see how awesome
that is checkmate
right all right well let's let's figure
out how we're gonna get this Queen well
one we have to get them to the G file
and then two we'll have to get them to
g2 so how would who's stopping us from
getting to the G file right now
that's night yes if only this night
wasn't here okay so let's get this night
out of the way so we can get the g5 and
get them checkmated okay so we don't
want to just throw them anywhere it's
like I don't care just take it whatever
we want to we want to play good so 9 2 H
5 excellent because now white finally
figures out hey you know I should
probably do something about this
checkmate thing okay so he really
doesn't want the Queen to go here so
does anybody know what his defenses of
this
it's Bishop back to c1 okay so now the
bishop is stopping the checkmate so who
can we like put in the way of the on
this diagonal who can we put on this
diagonal so then maybe we can play Queen
to g5 on the next move
so see we want to get something in the
way of this bishop so we can play the
move Queen to g5 good night yeah let's
just get them in there all right so so
he'll take okay so he's temporarily
stopping g5 so we'll take back and now
it's like well you know my King can't
move
move its calls for desperate measures
but Elliott he doesn't give up
he decides all right I can't stop Queen
the g5 but I'll play Knight to e2 so
when you play Queen to g5 check
I'll just black my knight and you know I
just play a game where I'm just down a
knight and at least I'm not getting
checkmated right so after pawn takes
pawn pawn takes pawn
mr. milli has a crushing move here
exploring up pin who does this guy think
he's defending like am defending them
the g3 pot that's so the g3 pawn in
reality isn't protected so what should
we do to the hanging pawns tank ohm
check and I guess what we get to do now
I don't think we really want to take
anything here isn't that what our dream
was right Queen to g2 and just make them
software don't want to just make
themself okay may feel a little bit but
when you have checkmate it's always it's
always good to play checkmate right all
right all right all right
good job good job all right now there
was a kid in here the other day right
today from a New York City he's taking
Grand Master lessons let's see how good
this kid is all right so our hero has
the black pieces here okay so white
starts out efore black counters East six
the French defense okay so you'd usually
recommend I'll play d4 but but the kid
from New York plays I Knight f3
so black counters d5 it brings out his
other Knight to c3 here so you just get
this problem okay so now
remember in the opening we don't want to
move the same piece you know all around
so so 95 doesn't make too much sense
here so when you tax it and now white
plays check which is alright because now
when he when he blocks it you know this
Knight to e5 isn't looking so silly
anymore okay but instead he takes takes
with the piece that was pinning them
Bishop takes check so Bishop takes and
now he decides not to play Knight takes
D seven but Knight back to f3 not very
good so Bishop the c6 protects the pawn
so now he gets in d4 Knight out and now
II five attacks the bishop so so instead
of panicking he just moves it back and
it'll be okay
so when he takes pawn takes okay so so
now it looks like white is up a pawn
right but this guy is doubled and this
guy is gonna be an easy target right now
so so right now he's got one defender
and one attacker so who can help out
attack this pawn for four black here and
there's only one piece that can do it it
looks like six the night yeah Knight to
g6 just attack right
why should try to hold on to it like
playing Queen to e2 but he doesn't he
moves the knight again not recommended
try to get castle or something or
protect the point alright so so he takes
it and now he castles so now black has
the opportunity to give something to
white that he doesn't want so you've all
heard that double pawns are bad right
double pawns are bad because they're on
the same line and they can't really
protect each other what do you think
about triple pawns you
think they're pretty good or do you
think they're bad as well yeah they look
like goofballs okay and there and if
they're triple pawns usually they're
going to be triple isolated pawns as
well so pretty good you can't resist
them
all right so now he plays Queen to f6 to
attack this pawn so he's like you're not
gonna get my triple pawn so big mistake
for white so what do you think black
plays in response to Bishop to b2
because what was that Bishop doing on c1
that was so important that he's no
longer doing
yeah Sundaram they forgot to protect the
night so yep you're out of here night
all right so now he does a discover and
attack here okay does everybody see what
when he plays the move c4 he's true he's
attacking this pawn but what else is he
attacking yes you're doing so good you
were one for one you want to just pass
and you can still be one for one see how
this Bishop is attacking the pawn is
that what you were gonna say all right
all right fair enough all right so so
what's funny is he should actually take
it but he castles to protect that that
precious Jeep on okay so now Queen to d4
excellent alright no matter if you're
losing should always be trained to
checkmate your opponent so what is white
threatening here with Queen to d4
yes yes the pawn on g7 and noticed that
this would be checkmate right all right
so so he's got to defend that so he
plays ePHI okay so now white backs up so
now Scott finally realizes hey that
checkmate on on the G file looks pretty
cool maybe I can try it what move would
Scott make right now to try a checkmate
on g2 so so look at the whole board here
okay so so notice the Queen is attacking
g2 right who else is in the same Lane as
g2 for a black here okay it's true yeah
so the night the night right it's on the
same line but I'm also this bishop okay
so if he pushes this pawn or even takes
the pawn he's threatening checkmate you
see bishop Queen and in this in this
position we would always take with the
Queen because queen takes pawn it's
checkmate
alright so who thinks White's gonna see
this right he does so how would you stop
this checkmate I mean checkmates a
pretty big thing okay if we don't stop
it we lose so unfortunately this Queen
would not be very good at snapping this
checkmate like if you touched your Queen
I would be so happy because it's touch
move you touched it you move it cuz it
cuz if you try to stop it like this you
flat out just lose the Queen because
this point is in a pin so it can't move
it cannot even take the bishop and
you're out of luck and obviously if you
go here I'll just take and so forth okay
so
so so how is white gonna stop this
checkmate because he just played the
move d4 I'm covering the bishop I can't
resist all right Sundaram all right rich
pawn the G part or the F pawn G okay the
Jeep on that point also works alright
that's what's played in the game at
least
alright so now he wants to checkmate
again who who else
yeah I think you already said who else
can help checkmate if not the bishop who
else can come I'm gonna attack the
knight all right Knight to f4
threatening threatening the G pause okay
so now white decides to play rook to f2
and he thinks he's doing great
I just stopped all your checkmates look
at me big New York City over here
alright so now which pawn of whites is
in a pin anybody but Jeep on yeah
alright
so interesting the Jeep on is in a pen
how can we exploit the fact is G pawn is
in a pen meaning this G pawn is going
nowhere and we do a cool move here
perhaps a check perhaps a knight fork
so if you're looking for your captures
and your checks you're like Oh Queen
takes pawn no good because rook takes a
fantastic Knight to h3 the fork so he
moves Knight takes King takes so you
might as well just keep the checks
coming so now you should play King to F
or g1 here right and protect the pawn
but instead he goes to f1 so we can just
take the pawn just take up everything we
can
so now after f4 we could go we'll just
take check King here we check again and
so now key position here we could trade
Queens or we could do something much
better when you're on the attack you
don't want to trade pieces you want to
go for the throat you want to get them
so everybody take a minute and try to
find a great move for black and what
what do you think the best move in all
it just is a move that ends with
checkmate right so try to find checkmate
in one an easy way to find a checkmate
in one problem is just looking for every
single check and then if you can't find
a move for white guess what you got it
all right all right Sundaram where do
you think checkmate is correct the queen
two squares down game over all right
perfect
all right so so great so I'm gonna go
play this kid from New York City and
look like so much fun and I'll be back
in just a second tell you how how I did
I'm back and I had the the white pieces
against them and boy it was a fun one
all right here we go
all right so I start out he for thinking
that he was gonna play e5 but he just
saw somebody play the French defense so
that's what he decided to play so d4
Knight to c6 attacks the pawn so just
keep attacking pawn takes pawn takes
Knight to b4 so so Knights it shouldn't
be out you know in in the opponent's
territory without a good plan I mean
this is he's just asking for it to be
captured almost but luckily it is
defended by this bishop all right so so
I bring my pawn up Knight to c3 here c5
so now I play the move d6 and now he
takes the pawn and uses a little lesson
out of my playbook and goes oh oh so so
so now when the people do that they
really want you to take here okay so
what would have he played if I would
have fallen for his trap here Black has
a really good move here Knight to see to
check okay and then King here and Knight
takes in reality it's not so good
because I guess I could have played a
Knight to d5 and now threatening the
same thing as a minus
check mate possibly you'll have to
sacrifice the Queen but anyhow I'm like
okay well I don't want to take it you
psyche me out so I play a3 I'm like so
now when a piece is hanging when a piece
can get captured for nothing it's called
on pre okay and he's got two pieces the
knight and the bishop I'm free meaning
he moves one I'll take the other okay
but he finds another a decent move here
Queen to a5 so now why is pawn takes
Knight not a good idea for
me yes yep I would lose my rook and
that's no fun okay so I don't want to
lose my rook all right but I still want
his knight to move somewhere so I can
take his bishop or something okay so all
I have to do is either protect the rook
or move the rook and guess what he'll
have two pieces hanging still right so
so what I should play here is just
Bishop to e3
unfortunately I play the move Bishop to
d2 I'm thinking wow I'm so good I got
this all in a line here but what
happened when I put my Bishop the d2
which piece of his is no longer under
attack when I put my bishop to d2 his
Bishop right so now his bishops no
longer hanging so now all he has to do
now is bring his knight back to a6 and
things would be looking good for him
well at least he didn't lose a piece but
he plays the move Bishop to e5 so now I
can take the pawn and he takes back now
I have an opportunity to win his queen
and unfortunately I do not see it I see
it on the next move which is too too
slow so so let's look at this Queen so
he can't move to the a file right now
right or else the rook will take it he
can go to b6
that's his retreat he can go here and
take our pawn and he can't go to b3 and
he can't go to c4 so right now as long
as we don't let them get to b6 we're
gonna be the best okay
and to be - so if we can somehow put
somebody on a square that protects both
b2 and b6
guess what the Queen will have no safe
spit to go to so anybody have any ideas
so if we play our queen somewhere like
if we play our queen to a for let's say
he'll be so excited to take it and then
we trade right let's take a look at rook
to a4 for instance if we play Brooke to
a4 Queen goes back to b6 and now he's
safe okay so what happens when we move
this Knight
let's say we move our Knight anywhere is
a queen under attack yes okay good so
when we move our Knight
the queen is under attack however if we
play our Knight - here let's say he can
play the b6 RB - so is there any place
we could put our knight data attacks b6
and uh protects b2 there is one Magic
Square I think and that square would be
everybody at home a4 all right all right
so unfortunately I play queen - E - uh
you know pinning the bishop and when it
plays d6 now I see oh man Knight to a4
looks really good too bad my queen isn't
on d1 defending b3 all right so too
little too late that's why you have to
be precise and chest goes when you have
a tactic 1 move but then it's gone the
next if you don't capitalize on it all
right so d6 this piece is in a pin what
do we do to pin pieces we attack them so
how do we attack this Bishop here
let's be really greedy we don't want to
trade a night for the bishop we want to
trade what for the bishop I'll pawn
right so I tack pin pieces all right
place f6 we take take and now we got
Knight d5 threatening the check and he
doesn't see those Queens under attack so
so now we got a pretty easy game here
Knight takes pawn takes rook takes the
pawn Knight to e7 Bishop takes the pawn
so now we're doing good
so Knight to f5 will bring this night
out just get more pieces into the attack
here so b6 we can just yeah we can just
take Knight takes pawn we're up so much
material might as well just crush them
so now he thinks he's slick here he
attacks our Queen okay so let's try to
figure out a checkmate in this position
it's not checkmate in one it's checkmate
in about two moves here all right so
remember in order to find a checkmate
right we're going to look for our checks
and our captures obviously anywhere our
Knight goes it's going to be check
however he'll take our queen
the rook excellent rook to e7 check
let's say he goes this way all right so
now notice this rook and Bishop are in
the same line so we can do a discovered
check here okay so if we just move our
rook down one check right the King has
to go here and then where is checkmate
notice that the knight is protecting f7
rook up
checkmate excellent and then in the game
after rookie seventh King goes here and
where is the checkmate
notice that this rook is defended by the
bishop so we don't have to worry about
him taking it all we have to do is put
the king and check where the piece
cannot get taken and it will be
checkmate
this way Knight f7 checkmate and that is
the game that is the Swiss Miss
tournament it was fun
this just in Aleks Marlar and Jim
McLoughlin won the tournament and Harper
Evan Smith is now rated 1899 all right